so to the average person you know that's
watching this to the business people
number one is alphabet Tesla who has
done more uh uh than a lot of these guys
can argue because he's actually tried to
make an impact and uh uh they're not
even in the top 12 okay and then even on
the SMP I think the score wasn't uh
sufficient enough where he was removed
from it he got criticized for it can you
pull up the tweet that Elon Musk has on
what he said about it I think Elon has a
tweet about ESG uh I sent you as well
just so uh uh
right there yeah Exxon is rated top 10
best in the world for environment social
and governance by S P 500 while Tesla
didn't even make the list ESG is a scam
it has weaponized by phony social
justice Warriors okay guys like him this
doesn't help him startup guys coming up
they want to raise Capital but no your
score isn't good we're not going to give
you 100 million dollars or 200 million
dollars 300 million dollars the average
guy that's got a job making 82 grandiers
like come on Vivek you want me to I
already have so many different issues
I'm trying to worry about who's going to
run for office I want to know whether
you know the Joe Burrough from
Cincinnati is going to win the Super
bowl or not I'm still celebrating Messi
won the World Cup well he's the greatest
of all time you want me to add another
acronym to my list of warning about ESG
why should I care what would you say to
that so it's a good question maybe you
shouldn't care
and here's here's gonna be a good case
for not caring if you are fine with your
own money being used to advance a
climate agenda or a racial Equity agenda
if you are fine with using your dollars
to tell Apple that they have to adopt a
racial Equity hiring system that they
don't want to adopt or that that oil
companies should produce less oil even
if that means higher prices at the pump
there's no problem with this because
that's what a good number of people
would want to do with their own money
turns out though most Americans don't
want to advance that agenda with their
own money their hard-earned life savings
their 401K accounts their retirement
accounts their brokerage accounts they
don't want that well it turns out the
rude surprises guess what your money is
being used to advance those agendas
anyway so you think you go to The Ballot
Box and vote every November that's what
you said people are concerned about
guess what I got news for you you're
already voting every day without your
knowledge with your own hard-earned
dollars to do it for policies that
undermine the very objectives that you
think you're voting for when you pull
that lever at The Ballot Box and so
they're making a farce out of your vote
that's just the first thing so now you
go to the Gas Pump and you're paying
five dollar gas you know last summer
on one hand you are using your 401k
account to cause oil companies to
produce less oil which causes gas prices
to go up yet with the other hand you're
also paying five dollar gas so you're
left holding the bag both ways well some
client in China
gets to invest in a Chinese BlackRock
fund that gets to own Petro China which
is buying up some of the projects on the
other side so the question is if you are
willing to sacrifice investment return
in your dollars and your hard-earned
savings to advance a one-dimensional
vision of how to solve climate change or
address systemic racism through quota
systems or whatever then there's no
problem for you you need not worry about
this in fact I have good news for you
that's exactly what's happening with
your money if you did not want to
advance those agendas with your own
hard-earned dollars I have bad news for
you your money is probably being used to
advance those agendas anyway and so on
one hand you didn't get that promotion
at work because we don't have
meritocratic hiring systems at many
companies anymore because of the S
sprung of the ESG movement on the other
hand the five percent that you put away
into your 401k account your money was
actually used to create that very
situation so if that bothers you then be
bothered and if not it's leave it alone
can I follow up with that
I like what you said initially when you
said listen you know rather than just
kind of harping about the problem I
actually developed something more of a
solution the name of your company will
strive strive respect we'll get to that
but I want to kind of touch on the at
the average person because I have
conversations with the average person
you know average people about saving
money and investing money and it is a
heavy task to ask them to start a 401k
and to even know what the S P 500 is and
take out an index fund and take out 10
of your paycheck so like it's what half
of Americans don't even invest period
right and then we can we can have a
whole other conversation of how many
Americans fill up their gas tank but
when you get into S P 500 you're
investing in these 500 companies in the
you know the large cab companies
you see people's mind being like all
right what the hell's an SB 500 what's
this what's this and now we're getting
so far down the rabbit hole of investing
and the Nuance well it's actually
BlackRock that actually owns the font
that's managing the money and that's who
you're advancing your 401K with and by
the way the shareholders are doing this
and that and they're you know their
social credits and like you go down and
it's like I'm just as an investor I'm
like dude I just want to have a 401k and
and and make a return so for the Pat's
question so it's such a nuanced
conversation because I'm really hearing
this for the first time like because you
were in the inner Plumbing the mechanics
of this you're seeing this so it's like
on one hand
to his question why should the average
investor care I get it but what can they
even do about it they're not at
shareholder meetings they're not in the
right you know in there so it's like
even if someone hears this and reads the
book it's like all right I'm with you
Vivek what's up it's like no just keep
investing your 401k best I mean that's
what I found it's strive right so I mean
it's it's funny and now I've got this
company it sounds like you know I'm
saying all this because that could mean
that you could you know it's actually
the other way no no I actually
wholeheartedly think that you actually
have a point here you've got to you got
to fill that void because people didn't
have a choice I'll just tell you a story
though actually it's on my flight down
here today I was you know writing a
chapter in my next book is going to be
coming out it's gonna be about a lot of
the same stuff you're really writing
these books buddy you're doing I like
writing actually clearly it turns out I
I uh I discovered I was doing biotech
for you know seven years as a CEO and
seven years investor before that I
didn't know I was going to be this uh I
was going to love you're on auditing
books this much now I'm kind of wearing
this hat as an author but anyway the the
story I was writing in in the chapter I
was working on today was actually about
Frederick Douglass in this country so
you know Frederick Douglass obviously
abolitionist so one of my one of my
favorite stories about Frederick
Douglass was that he actually so he was
lent out as a slave so not only did he
work the family that owned him they
loaned him out to be able to get extra
income or Curry favor with neighbors and
so one day he was learning he was he was
doing work for the neighbor but they
actually the neighbors took quite a
liking to him so the mother figure of
that family decided she wanted to teach
him how to read
she did that while her husband was at
work one day he came home from work
early he found her teaching how to read
he was livid because he said a man with
knowledge is not fit to be a slave so
the funny part is Frederick Douglass
may not have actually probably did not
want to be learning how to read he was
just a kid most kids don't like to be
sat down and taught how to read either
he's no different than other kids but he
heard that
he knew how much
they did not want him to know how to
read and he thought okay look that's
probably pretty important for me to
figure out that changed his life he then
started asking other kids as they were
coming home the white boys were actually
allowed to go to school he would pick up
little bits and pieces of knowledge
pieced enough together how to read once
he knew how to read he became an
autodide act a self-taught guy one of
the great figures in American history so
why do I bring that up
there was actually a rule change this
year the Biden Administration tries to
weave ESG into retirement plans so they
changed the rules this year the federal
rule governing retirement plans it's a
boring law called orisa okay
what they said was actually now these
fund managers can take
social benefits what they call
collateral benefits other than
investment return into account before
they weren't allowed to
now in the initial rule what they said
was you had to disclose that prominently
that you had to tell the investor the
mom the pop the doctor the nurse that
hey I'm not just Investing For
maximizing your financial return but I'm
also advancing these other objectives
but in the final rule that they actually
passed that disappeared because they
said that if you do disclose it that's
going to have a chilling effect it's
going to stop people from using these
ESG factors same thing as Frederick
Douglass right
don't tell them because if you do tell
them then they're going to be empowered
to make decisions so even if these
issues bore you before let me tell you
they are purposefully trying to keep you
from seeing it just like that Father
Figure in that family wanted to
purposely make sure that Frederick
Douglass did not know how to read
because a man with knowledge is not fit
to be a slave well you know they told
slaves back then they said you know it's
sit down shut up and do as you're told
I think we live in a moment in American
history where that's what many Americans
are told sit down shut up and do what
you're told and you know what at a
certain point in time you might even get
used to it that then becomes the new
Norm to sit down shut up and do as
you're told without recognizing that
your own dollars that you put your
hard-working days into are sacrificed to
advance somebody else's social agenda
that would make your blood boil if you
actually knew what was going on and so
maybe closing your eyes makes yourself
feel better but once you open your eyes
that's when you're actually empowered to
act with your own dollars and so
I hope there are tons of other
competitors offering other options that
allow people to invest in the market and
derive a financial return without having
to subsidize these Progressive one-sided
causes I mean today they're Progressive
tomorrow they could be conservative for
all I know but subsidized causes that
they disagree with
but it's not going to happen either if
there are no Market Alternatives which
is why I started one but it's also not
going to happen if if all individuals
are just simply apathetic okay you'd
have never had emancipation in this
country if a bunch of people were just
apathetic about it well I'm not you and
I'm using an analogy I'm not saying that
this is the same thing of course as
slavery in the United States but I'm
doing it to address your question of why
should people care if you've been lulled
into submission and you're okay with
that in a certain sense you are just a
psychologically in a psychological sense
of slave of the people who enforce those
agendas onto you using your labor
in this case the dollar you earn from
your labor as the weapon to enforce that
agenda on you so if you like this clip
and you want to watch another one click
right here and if you want to watch the
entire podcast click right here
[Music]